[Applause]
bts just pulled off the ultimate
surprise
bringing megan the stallion on stage for
a performance of the butter remix
just get ready it all went down sunday
night during the second of four sold out
shows in los angeles when the houston
rapper popped up in the middle of the
stage for her verse on the hit remix of
the track
[Applause]
yeah needless to say the bts army
totally went wild and meg she crushed it
[Applause]
[Music]
on monday the savage rapper posted a few
snaps from the epic moment writing quote
last night was so amazing thank you to
my friends bts for having me a lot of
body body yada yada of course bts and
megan were originally scheduled to
perform the song live on tv for the
first time at the american music awards
earlier this month but the rapper
dropped out due to an unexpected
personal matter the day before the big
show
i did what i had to do but as they say
the show must go on and not only did bts
slay their performance of butter
the k-pop super group joined coldplay to
perform their song my universe for the
first time together on stage we're just
here to have a good time with the armies
and it ended up being a big night for
bts the band took home three amas artist
of the year best pop song and favorite
pop duo or group and before the show
they couldn't help but get excited about
performing for the army in person again
we waited this for
so
so long time so it's like a dream yeah
it's like a dream i mean we actually
dreamed of this dream so it's crazy
[Music]
you